네. 빌사남이 간다. 오늘은 삼성역에
왔습니다. 네, 지금 삼성역에 왔는데
지금 보시면 알겠지만 여기 그
영동대로 공사를 하고 있습니다. 뭐
시작한지 그렇게 오래되진 않았는데
아마 엄청 오랫동안 이렇게 공사할
것으로 좀 예상이 돼요. 지하
6층까지 좀 파 가지고 지금
지하철뿐만 아니라 여기에 이제 복합
시설을 좀 만들 계획이거든요. 그리고
이제 광역 버스도 이쪽으로 갈 수
있게끔 저희가 강남역가 보면은 그
웬만한 경기도 가는 광역 버스들이 다
있잖아요. 근데 이런 버스 정류장을
이쪽에도 만들 예정입니다. 아마
삼성역에 오기가 더 편해질 거
같아요. 지금 뭐 GTX까지 다
들어오기 때문에 이런 수도권에 계신
분들도 여기 삼성역에 이동하기에
굉장히 편할 것으로 좀 예상이
됩니다. GBC가 제가 알고 있기로는
아직 서울시랑 좀 협의가 안
됐습니다. 그러니까 이제 기부 체납을
좀 해야 되거든요. 시간이 좀 많이
더 소요되고 있어요. 낙차를
2014년도에 낙차를 받았잖아요.
그래서 그때 10조가 넘는 금액에
낙찰를 받았는데 아직까지 지금
11년이 지났는데도 불구하고 아직까지
지금 저 상태로 유지용입니다. 그래서
그러다 보니까 GBC 인근의 상권이
다 죽었어요. 그래서 오랫동안 저렇게
비어 있다 보니까 그래서 상인분들도
여기 장사가 안 된다고 말씀을 좀
되게 많이 하세요. 지금 아직까지
서울시랑 협의 중이기 때문에 향후 몇
년간은 지금 상권이 좀 좋지 않을
것으로 예상이 됩니다. 네. 그래서
지금 GBC 쪽으로 가고 있는데 여기
잠깐 왔는데도 외국인 관광객들이
많아요. 그래서 관광객들이 실제로
코엑스를 많이 찾습니다. 강남 스타일
동상도 있고 여기 지하에 코엑스의
외국인 관광객들이 찾을 만한 명소들도
되게 많거든요. 보시면은 외국인
관광객들도 많이 찾는 그런 곳이라고
보시면 될 거
[음악]
같습니다. 여기 현수막에도 보셨겠지만
원래는 105층까지 올리려고 했어요.
그래서 롯데 타워보다는 더 높게
지으려고 했다가 여러 공사
비용이라든지 그리고 여러분들 건물이
저렇게 높게 초고층 빌딩으로 되면
방공 시설이 필요합니다. 그래서 방공
시설 비용이 굉장히 많이 들어요.
54층짜리 건물 세 개동으로 설계를
변경했습니다. 그리고 건물이 제가
알고 있기로는 한 55층, 56층이
되는 순간부터 비용이 더 많이
들어갑니다. 그래서 그런 비용들
때문에 가성비로 좀 지은 거 같아요.
네. 그리고 이제 공사가 많이
딜레이됐던 이유 중에 하나가 원래
여기가 봉문사가 가지고 있었어요.
그러다가 이제 한전에 넘겼는데 한전에
넘길 때 뭐 그런 이슈들이 좀
있었다라고 합니다. 그러다 보니까
동원사에서 여기에 이제 문제 제기를
좀 했었어요. 네. 그것 때문에
기간이 좀 많이 딜레이가 됐습니다.
진짜 14년도에 매입해 가지고
아직까지 지금이 상태라는게 비용적인
측면에서 굉장히 좀 그 안타깝긴
하지만 어 지어지고 나면은 여기 때는
좀 진짜 많이 좋아지지 않을까 그렇게
예상을 합니다. 그리고 지금 여기
공사하고 있는 부분을 공원으로 만들
예정이에요. 강남구에 이렇게 큰
대로변에 걸어다닐 수 있는 곳을
만든다는게 엄청 상징적인 거고 정말
많은 사람들이 강남을 왔을 때 이곳을
찾지 않을까 그렇게 예상을 합니다.
뭐 한국의 타임스퀘어를 만들겠다라고
해 가지고 여기 허가를 좀 많이
내줬어요. 그래서 실제로 지금 여기
허가가 좀 많이 나와 있습니다.
그리고 이쪽에도 나중에 뭐 광고판이
달리고 여기 일대가 광고판이 다
달리면 관광 명소가 되지 않을까?
네. 그렇게 예상을 합니다.
네. 그래서 저희가 삼성역에 중계를
한 건 중에 굉장히 좀 잘
매입했다라고 생각하는 사례에 좀 와
있습니다. 뒤에 보이는 저 리모델링
사례인데 저 건물은 저희가 이제 작년
1월 달에 이제 빌딩 시장이 굉장히
안 좋을 때 중계를 한 사례인데 저거
전에 매입했던 분이 한 435억
정도에 매입을 했습니다. 정말 던지는
매물이었어요. 저희가 중계했던 금액이
무려 100억 정도가 절충이 돼서 어
한 337억 거의 한요 정도에 중계를
했습니다. 굉장히 잘 매입한 사례고
여기 블록이 투자 가치가 되게
좋거든요. 그래서 지금 GBC의
영향을 가장 많이 받는 데가 바로이
같은 블록에 있는 건물입니다. 그래서
대지 평단가로 봤을 때 한 1억 7천
1억 8천이 좀 안 되는 금액으로
매입했는데 투자 가치가 굉장히 좀
좋은 곳이에요. 물론 이제 이게
GBC가 계속 딜레이되고 좀 그런
부분 때문에 시간이 좀 오래 걸릴 것
같긴 하지만 그래도 투자해 놓기에는
좀 강남 지역에서 좀 제일 괜찮지
않나? 네. 그렇게 생각을
[음악]
합니다. 어, 삼성역 좀 총평을
하자면 어, 저 개인적으로는 강남에서
제일 투자 가치가 있는 거 중에
하나가 저는 명품거리랑 삼성역
쪽이라고 생각을 하거든요. 그래서
삼성역 쪽은 워낙 지금 개발 호재도
많고 컨텐츠를 넣을 만한 곳이 엄청
많아요. 지금 영동대로 여기 공원화도
그렇고 진짜 광화문 광장처럼 될
겁니다. 그 정도로 폭도 넓고 저렇게
사람이 걸어다닐 수 있는 그리고 이제
저렇게 정강판이 많고 콘텐츠가 많은
그런 거리가 없거든요. 저는 앞으로
강남의 투자 가치는 삼성력 쪽에 더
크다라고 생각을 합니다. 지금 여기
GBC랑 여기 공사가 워낙 시간이
오래 걸려서 여러분들이 지금
투자한다라고 하면은 시간이 굉장히 좀
많이 소요될 거 같아요. 근데 내가
그거를 감안하고 좀 장기적으로
보겠다라고 하면은 저는 삼성력 인근에
투자하는 거를 강력하게 추천을
합니다. 영향을 받는 데가 사실 여기
금방밖에 없거든요. 예를 들어서 뭐
저기 삼성역 저쪽 뭐 삼성
중앙력이라든지 뭐 선정 능력이라든지
거기도 이제 삼성인데 거기까지 영향이
클 거 같진 않아요. 영향을 받는
곳은 여기 블록이라든지 여기 건너편의
대치동이라든지 여기 인근 일대가 좀
상권에 영향을 좀 많이 받을 것으로
좀 예상이 되고 현대차 4혹으로
인해서 가격이 많이 올라갈 것
같습니다. 그리고 여기 이제 54층
지으면 아마 지금 거의 센터필드 정도
높이 수준이 될 거 같아요.
예상컨인데 그러면은 꽤 상당히
높거든요. 그리고 여기 상주 인구가
정말 몇십만 명이 될 겁니다. 그래서
여기 인근에 뭐 상권이라든지 관련돼
있는 업체들도 많이 이전을 할 거
같아요. 그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요. 여러분들이 추가적으로 내가
궁금한 곳이 있다라고 하면은 댓글
남겨 주시면 제가 직접 찾아가서 그
영상을 촬영하도록 하겠습니다. 네,
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다.
빌딩은 역시 빌사남.